every television fan gets used to the
pain of seeing their favorite series
canceled and we've all seen shows die
because of ratings budget or cast
problems sometimes though the plug gets
pulled for reasons that were totally
avoidable and sometimes even downright
dumb holy set destruction Batman the 60s
Batman series starring Adam West isn't
anyone's idea of hard-hitting superhero
entertainment but it's a campy classic
and one that might have stayed on the
air longer than two years if the network
hadn't gotten a destructive itch execs
at ABC weren't willing to continue
funding Batman after its first two
seasons so they decided to sell the
rights to NBC meanwhile NBC wanted to
make sure Batman's existing sets and
props were part of the deal
unfortunately during a brief production
hiatus between networks and ABC exec had
the sets destroyed the deal died and the
Caped Crusader hung off his cowl Robin
Hood killed Robin Hood Jonas Armstrong
started BBC One's Robin Hood decided to
vacate Tulia role after the show's third
season but instead of recasting the part
with a new actor the producers opted to
simply kill off the character since
they'd already killed off Robins loved
Maid Marian that left the supporting
cast to carry the show you know the one
named after a guy who was dead although
Robin Hood's writing staff was willing
to try a revamp the network decided
there was no point in continuing young
justices lousy toy sales when Warner
Brothers hit pay dirt with Young Justice
which posted triple digit ratings
increases for his timeslot on Cartoon
Network it seemed safe to assume they
went more than two seasons but the show
was axed after only 46 episodes
prompting outcry and widespread
speculation despite great ratings the
real reason it was cancelled was
frustrating to its fans funding for the
show came from a merchandising tying
deal with Young Justice action figures
from Mattel
but when low sales killed the toy line
the show quickly followed suit it's
unfair when a show that's supposed to be
a 30-minute toy commercial is actually
pretty great but the toys aren't Kingdom
Hospital vs. CSI few places are scarier
than hospitals so when a horror maestro
Stephen King made a deal with ABC to
write and produce the haunted medical
drama Kingdom Hospital it seemed like a
perfect fit
sadly the show's sole season was kind of
a mess not on screen where it offered a
solid batch of episode that earned two
Emmy nominations but behind the scenes
we're struggles between king of the
network doomed it convinced ABC wasn't
promoting kingdom hospital enough king
paid for a print ad campaign only to see
his efforts foiled when execs moved it
to a different time slot King learned
yet again that while ghosts are scary
which truly terrifying is dealing with
network executives cast into
cancellation hell after Buffy the
Vampire Slayer ended in 2003 fans
flocked to the show spin-off angel which
was entering its fifth season after
years on the renewal bubble angel
enjoyed a post Buffy ratings bump series
creator Joss Whedon approached WB
network president in Jordan eleven about
an early pickup for season six although
Whedon's move wasn't purely a power play
he was looking for extra security for
angels team who'd endured years of
passing of gigs while waiting for
last-minute renewals but xi saw it as an
ultimatum the president pulled the plug
all for the sake of throwing his weight
around
although the network later admitted it
was a mistake it was too late to revive
angel thanks for watching and don't
forget to Like and subscribe if you want
more